do you want to introduce yourself to the
world who are you
it's me dodis
what is this
i've been abusing this a lot every time
like someone wants something from me i'm
like
what does this mean what are they using
it means
i don't know is that like one stop in
like hawaii or something yeah yeah yeah
yeah exactly it's like actually yeah
i just like that i like it because i
don't have to speak i just
what are you mute
well since uh moving to japan i've been
doing this lately like
it's like yes i understand so yeah is
that just like nod to other people like
yeah just no no matter what like if i'm
passing by somebody they see me i'm like
[Laughter]
it's automatically
just you just do that to everyone
everyone you pass on the street you know
only if like they i don't know they like
make eye contact there's a narrow
hallway or they make eye contact i'll be
like
it's just automatic i don't know
actually it was crazy i saw the um
i saw this lady on the phone yeah yeah
she's talking on her cell phone like
this
like this
and she she was going
yeah yeah yeah yeah and i was like
that's the craziest thing i've ever seen
in my life
like why are you why are you cradling
like a baby
yeah yeah she's bowing on the phone like
constantly i've seen i've seen [ __ ]
salarymen do like full like 90 degree
like yeah full-on bowing on the phone
yeah why i don't honest honestly
honestly like i i bow by like habit as
well sometimes
like when i like end the conversation i
just like have to bow like it's just
like a knee joke yeah it is it is right
to do this yeah yeah yeah even if i'm
like on the phone like yeah hey
yeah you know like i'm like they can't
see me bowing right now
it is physically impossible for you to
say hi on the phone without like moving
your neck yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you can't just go hi
hi yeah like
that vein popping yeah i'm not gonna
try not to bounce try not to bounce yeah
it's a wonderful combo when
i guess the reason why you're impressed
by bowing is because you just moved here
but also i mean i mean i mean
audience who do not know who you are do
you want to explain what you do on
youtube who you are yeah i'm a i'm a
loser that animates my life i guess and
then when i'm bored of animating my life
i do
fun random stuff
that you know and then like
like what yeah like what's the random
stuff you do
um
game
no
yes it is yes it is what do you mean
well i make like little so
most time like a story time animator but
yeah yeah i don't really yeah you got to
keep the mic pretty close to you oh
hello
yeah
you gotta like you gotta like eat the
mic yeah yeah
yeah create like a baby and bow to it
yeah so you make other things
uh yeah i mostly make just animations
basically and then
um
that's about
that was the most funny force
yeah that's about it i just animate and
you're a member of geeks plus now aren't
you i am yeah yeah yeah how does it feel
to be in japan because you just moved
here like
three weeks ago i forgot
three weeks ago or something i can't
remember the time goes fly by fast
because like i'm just building furniture
constantly
that's how it always is yeah yeah yeah
yeah and then we're going to like
the japanese bank and then they try to
give me a bank account and i'm just like
sitting here and then there's like two
japanese ladies it's like translating
yeah yeah and they're they're like going
back and forth and then and literally i
got there at like 8 a.m yeah and then
went all the way to like i think we got
out like 7 p.m jesus the bank plus the
phone the phone too oh yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah one day it did be
like literally took like i don't know
like an entire day entire day yeah this
is and i felt useless too because i
can't speak the language yet right yeah
yeah
it was like sitting there and it just
like just like translating and yeah i
was uh applying for a visa to come here
oh it was a it was a it was death i i
though
when did you start when did you start
because i think i i basically was like
you know i'd been teasing them all about
how fun japan is and they'd be like oh
because originally i hate this guy he
would post like pictures of food and
stuff and i'm like i hate this [ __ ]
i i've i've played league with emily
indirect a lot and we obviously do our
videos together and uh
you know originally you're going to come
to japan in april 2020
so you were going to come in 2020 with
emily to come just hang out and visit
yeah and obviously as we all know what
happens
and then we're like don't worry
it'll open up soon it'll open up soon
yeah it'll open up it never opened up
yeah so it went up to like what 2021
like mid-2021 and i was like
i mean just you know
i'm like
you interested in like coming here no
actually no i think two years ago you
said
uh do you want to move there you asked
me and i was like all right i think i
asked emily i was like well i feel like
we should test japan to see if we like
it first yeah yeah yeah we're gonna
visit yeah because i've heard that
you've never left the states before
moving here to japan i oh yeah yeah i've
only been to canada and florida so i
live in maine oh that's two different
countries right
i like you i like the way he said i've
been to canada a different country and
florida almost
so japan japan was like a very big jump
there
yeah yeah so well my mom's cambodian
yeah yeah yeah like half chinese or
whatever
yeah uh but she never brought me to
cambodia because he's always like afraid
of like dangers like
yeah over there so i'm like
well
i guess i never got to visit ever yeah
yeah like literally ever because you're
close now though
yeah yeah exactly
now yeah i i hope it's more safe yeah so
jesus you'd like just like you
like flew the coop then because like you
went from not basically going out of
north america to [ __ ] moving to japan
just just just like that
not even visiting you are now just
living here well first of all the boys
were closed forever and ever and ever
and ever and ever waiting literally like
a year or whatever long i was dying in
my basement i was rotting i was there's
nothing to do there i was bored as hell
in my mom's basement my mom did my
laundry
she cooked for me
i was just like i was just chilling too
hard yeah the fact that like i didn't
want to do anything i was just right
right
yeah i was just like
playing video games i'm gonna be honest
yeah
i was just rotting away yeah and you
know finally the borders opened up and
then oh yeah i also gained i gained like
50 pounds and then i lost
20 pounds right then i regained 20
pounds and then i lost 20 30 pounds or
something so i've been yoyoing i just
sounds like i don't hurt in
general no it was just it was just cold
that just sounds like metabolism you
know like yeah adulthood is like gaining
a few pounds and you're just like [ __ ] i
need to go on a diet you like diet good
for a month you're like yes i have lost
those pounds i can keep going you don't
keep going and then you gain the pounds
back you're like [ __ ] i should die again
and then you start darling and then it's
like it's like a yo-yo between like the
same like 10 pounds or whatever you just
never win exactly it's very sad because
um
uh
i think before
2020 happened you know the whole covert
thing happened you know yeah i was gonna
visit japan yeah and i was like at my
peak i was like pretty skinny and like i
was at the you know i was comfortable
with my own body i was like i'm gonna
put myself out there and then a covert
hit and i was like oh and then i
i just became a baseball dweller again
it was very
so you decided just be just to like
[ __ ] get out and just like do
something just to get a change basically
so i've been i've been yearning to like
uh
just like i i went to i lived i used to
live in new york during college
art college right um and that was like
essentially like throwing myself out
there right into the wild right and i
miss that feeling of like just being
thrown into a wild yeah trying to figure
stuff out
not even like i just like the fact that
if you it's like what is this thing and
it's like it peaks it like peaks your
brain you're like wait this is this is
something different and yeah yeah in
maine or or just like united states like
any state you go to it's not really that
much different yeah except florida
except florida and then you get shot
and then dark
that's why i like about japan like yeah
like the whole like you have an umbrella
and you put it in the slot thing and
yeah
and it takes off oh you locked the
umbrella yeah
yeah and i was like this is the umbrella
yeah yeah
i was like this is crazy